The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, our goal
is to discuss some concepts
in this question of a kind of
population or ecosystem level
stability, resilience, and
associated sudden transitions
in populations.
And something about
diversity of populations.
We will revisit this
question of diversity
more on the last
class, where we're
going to discuss
some of these ideas
from the neutral
theory in ecology,
but it'll be a bit
of a preview today.
So what we're going
to do is start out
by just considering the dynamics
of just a single population,
where you have maybe a
one population that's
growing either logistically,
or via some cooperative kind
of dynamic.
So, single population.
And in here, we're going
to understand something
about this idea of
either logistic growth
as compared to something called
the Allee effect, whereby
the population has some
cooperative type dynamic.
So this is maybe logistic
versus the Allee effect.
And try to understand
how this Allee effect can
lead to the sudden transitions
that you read about
in the review.
And then we'll say something
about the Lotka-Volterra
competition model.
So this is a slightly
different model
from the Lotka-Volterra
predator-prey model
that we've all been
thinking about recently
over the last week or so.
But it's again, kind
of the simplest model
you might write
down that captures
this idea of interactions
between species.
In particular,
competitive interactions.
Then at the end, and depending
on how much time we have,
we'll either finish it or not.
We'll talk about some these
non transitive interactions.
The so-called rock,
paper, scissors,
RPS type interactions.
And some of the
measurements that
have been made both in male
mating strategies in lizards
in the California mountains, as
well as kind of a rock, paper,
scissors type dynamic that
was explored experimentally
by Benjamin Kerr in the context
of bacterial toxin production,
or chemical warfare bacteria.
And this subject
does come in a bit
into this question
of spatial structure,
and how spatial structure
may help facilitate
the stability of populations.
So there's this idea of that
non-transitive interactions,
whether you have Rock, Paper,
Scissor type interactions,
may facilitate coexistence of
either genotypes or species.
But in some of these
studies, there's
an argument that sometimes
this non-transitive interaction
may not be enough, but
then in the presence
of spatial structure,
maybe it does help.
On Thursday, the primary
topic of the class
will be trying to understand
the dynamics of populations
when their spatially extended.
So this will
transition naturally
into the subject on Thursday.
Are there any questions
about where we are here?
Or administrative type issues?
All right, so I just want to
make sure that we're first,
all on the same page.
We talk about logistic growth.
So we can think
about-- Well, what
are the simplest ways that we
might consider the population
dynamics of just a
single population.
Well, the logistic growth
is maybe the simplest model
you might write down, where the
population is at least bounded.
And I might even-- Maybe
I'll even just first draw
exponential growth,
just so that we can--
The very simplest
thing you might do
is you might just
say that N dot might
be equal to some r times n.
In this case, if
we plotted gamma,
the per capita rate
of population growth,
this is just some line at r.
In this case, the population
grows exponentially.
And that that means
that if you plot
say the number as a
function of time, well
it doesn't matter
where you start,
you always go to infinity.
Right?
Now we can compare this to the
logistic growth case, where
we just assume that
at low density,
indeed, we grow
exponentially at this rate r,
but then we have
a linear decrease
in this per capita
rate of growth
as a function of density.
So we might write this as
something that looks like this.
In which case, if we write
this per capita growth
rate of the population, as a
function of population size,
it starts out at r,
but then it goes to 0.
And indeed you, might
even if you'd like,
you could say that it goes
down to a negative value.
So in that case, you could
start at a population
size above the
carrying capacity k,
and you still come back down it.
One of things that we want
to make sure we understand
is what the bifurcation
structure of these equations
is going to look like.
In particular, we
can think about what
happens if we add some sort of
death rate to the population.
Right now, in this
case, a death rate
corresponds to is
something-- OK, we're looking
at the bifurcation diagram.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to think about what
happens if you look
at the size of the population.
In the bifurcation diagram,
what we typically do is
we look at the fixed points.
The fixed points
in n, as a function
of some external parameter.
And here, we might just
think about delta here
which is just some death rate.
The simplest way to
include this here would
be to have a minus delta n.
So the idea is that
there's this population.
It grows exponentially
at small sizes.
As the population size
grows, it might run out
of nutrients or so, and that
limits its overall population
size.
Then, we can add
another term here
which is corresponding
to something
about the quality
of the environment.
So this could be the amount of
hunting that is taking place,
or it could be a
reflection of pollutants
in the environment or so.
And what we want to
do is try to make
sure we understand how
the size of the population
will respond to some death rate.
Well maybe we'll go ahead
and do a verbal vote.
So in the review
that you guys read,
this was talking about
in these early warning
indicators in the context
of sudden transitions
and populations.
So this was saying
that whether you're
looking at a population, or
an ecosystem, or maybe even
other complex system,
such as climate regime
shifts, epileptic seizures,
and so forth, the authors were
arguing that in
response to a slowly
changing environmental
knob, the system
can experience a sudden
transition in the state.
Now, the question is here.
And the sudden transitions
that they were describing,
those were fold bifurcations,
or saddle-node bifurcations.
Where there's a
sudden transition
in say, the equilibrium.
Size of the population
is a function
of some external knob describing
the quality of the environment.
So the question is
whether this population
experiences such a full
bifurcation at least
to a sudden transition.
Do understand the question?
I'll say fold bifurcation.
I'll let you guys vote, just
so you can use your cards.
And this is a full bifurcation
as a function of this delta,
which is death rate.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
We have a majority
now that are saying
the answer is no,
this does not actually
have a fold bifurcation.
And the reason for
that is that we
can find the-- In the
absence of a death rate, what
is the equilibrium
population size?
k, right?
Indeed, what's going to happen
is that as we add this death
rate, we can just figure out,
OK well, the fixed points
occur when N dots equal to zero.
All of these things.
There's an n here, we
can divide by that.
Well we could just do it,
just so that we're all
on the same page.
So the fixed point.
What we want to do is
set N dot equal to zero.
That tells us that n times
r1 minus n over k minus delta
is equal to 0.
OK.
How many fixed points are there
going to be in the system?
Two.
Right, so indeed, this is N dot.
So n equal to zero is going
to be one fixed point,
but the other one
is going to be when
this thing is equal to zero.
And so then we end up
with 1 minus n over k,
is going to be equal
to some delta over r.
So we can see that
this stable fixed point
is going to decrease linearly
with this death rate delta.
And it's just going to
go smoothly to zero.
That's this key feature of
this bifurcation digraph.
So what happens is that we come
down like this, and indeed,
we could even continue this and
the bifurcation occurs here.
We want to draw--
This corresponds
to a stable fixed point.
And a dashed line is unstable.
In this case, this is the
stable and this is the unstable.
So this thing here
is what's known
as a trans-critical bifurcation.
And it's a bifurcation because
the fixed points do something.
In this case, they
exchange stability.
So what happens is that
this thing becomes unstable,
whereas the fixed
point at n equals
0 becomes a stable fixed point.
So there's no tipping
point or sudden transition
in this logistic growth as
you change the death rate.
All right, you can think
of it as a situation
here where the death
rate just kind of starts
pulling this thing down.
And this bifurcation occurs
when you pull it down--
when delta is equal to r.
And what this means is
that if you plot say,
the number as a function
of time, for low delta,
in particular, for delta
equal to zero then this
is your-- You come to
this equilibrium k.
Where as delta increases,
eventually you just
get to a situation where all of,
regardless of where you start,
you go extinct.
Now, in many cases, we don't
draw what happens down here
because n being less than
0 is not a physical thing.
But it's useful to think
about it mathematically,
because that's what tells you
that that was the bifurcation.
Are there any questions
about where we are here?
One thing that's valuable in
the case of-- well, in general--
is to switch between the
algebraic characterization
of the dynamics a system
and the graphical dynamics,
because you end up seeing
different things depending
on how you do it.
For the case of
the Allee effect,
we're just going to look at
it and analyze it graphically,
just because the equation
is a little bit cumbersome,
and I think don't provide
very much intuition.
What you can see is that
for the logistic growth,
other individuals
in the population
always decrease your
happiness as an individual.
So if you imagine that you are
some member of this population,
and having more
members the population
there is always
kind of bad for you,
because it decreases
your growth rate.
And to think about the
happiness of an individual, what
you typically want
to do is divide by n,
because you're thinking about
the per capita growth rate.
So that's telling you
about the ability hat
you will have to reproduce.
So what you did we do
is just divide by n.
What you can see is that
per capita division, gamma,
is a monotonically decreasing
function of the population
size.
This is saying that more
individuals in the population
just take up space,
resources, mate, something.
And so you as an
individual never benefit
from the presence of
other individuals.
Whereas, when you have the
Allee effect, what that's saying
is that over some range of
population size or densities,
there is a positive effect
of other individuals
in the population.
This is saying that if we
plot gamma, in particular,
the derivative of gamma with
respect to n is greater than 0
for some n.
This is just saying that if we
plot this per capita division
rate as a function of the
size of the population,
there's some region in which
this thing has positive slope.
And often, people
distinguish between
the so-called strong Allee
effect and the weak Allee
effect.
The strong Allee effect
corresponds to the situation
where at n equal to zero,
you start out with negative
per capita growth rates.
So this is just some
generic curve here,
that describes the Allee effect.
The important thing is that
it's coming up here at low n.
And what this
tells us is that we
will have some sort
of different dynamics
where this is going to be the
stable size of the population
here.
But there's also a minimal
size required for survival.
So if you start out below
this n, then you come down.
If you want you want,
you could call it
some-- This could be some
k, and this could be n-min.
This is saying if we plot
n as a function of time
starting with different
sizes of the population,
then indeed, this thing
is a stable state.
But the key thing is that
there's this other minimal size
required for survival.
So if you start out around here,
then just above it you come up,
but just below
it, you come down.
What do you say?
What you see is
that this population
that experiences the
strong Allee effect
has bistable fates.
So it's bistable.
This is bistable depending
on the starting size
n of the population.
Now, can somebody suggest
possible explanations
for why there might
an Allee effect?
AUDIENCE: Sexual reproduction?
PROFESSOR: Sexual reproduction.
And can you explain
that a little bit more?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
And basically, just
the need to find mates.
So this implies that
at some density,
sexual reproducing
species are expected
to have this Allee effect.
It doesn't mean
that the Allee fact
is super strong at
moderate sizes, right?
I think that this
statement is true,
but it might lead us to conclude
that these extreme dynamics
that we're talking about here
are relevant for every sexually
reproducing species.
But ultimately, the question
is maybe how big is this n-min?
If n-min is two, then it's
not a severe constraint
on the population.
Whereas if n-min is-- if you
need to have 100 California
condors in order to have
a viable population,
then that's a problem.
So there really is a
quantitative question
of how big is this minimal size.
Other suggestions of why it is
you might have an Allee effect?
AUDIENCE: The animal
species in groups?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Group hunting.
And are you aware of any cases
that have group hunting ?
AUDIENCE: Wolves?
PROFESSOR: That's
right, so, exactly.
Right, so wolves for
example, can take down
like bison, of large
animals they would never be
able to take down on their own.
So this could be this could be
wolves, it could be primates.
We historically did-- I guess
we still have some groups.
Societies will have
things like this.
But even at the
microscopic realm,
if you look at just bacteria
or yeast and so forth,
there are often cases where
food is generated or broken
down outside of the cell.
So any of these
cases where you have
secreted enzymatic breakdown.
That was an i.
Other thoughts?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Protection
from predators?
PROFESSOR: Right, protection.
And so this is the
flip side of this,
so this would be
predator avoidance.
Or an example of
that would be what?
AUDIENCE: Antelopes.
PROFESSOR: What do antelopes do?
AUDIENCE: They run in groups.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So the standard
example here is kind
of what herding behavior
of land animals, schooling
behavior of fish.
Of course, researchers
argue about to what degree
the benefits are primarily
this, versus something else.
I am not going to weigh
in on that debate.
But, I'd be surprised
if this were never true.
In all these examples, there's
clearly something cooperative
about the dynamics.
In that sense, it
kind of makes sense
to think there's some element
of cooperative growth,
whether it's on the hunting
side, or the protection side.
So if you look at
all these cases
these would all be very
naturally described
as some sort of cooperation.
I do want to highlight though,
that the Allee effect can
be caused by things that
lead to what you might
call effective cooperation.
So it's not like
obviously cooperative,
or not intentionally
cooperative,
but still has the same effect.
A nice example of this is what
we call predator satiation.
Can somebody guess
what this might mean?
Somebody's laughing so it's--
AUDIENCE: If there are
enough animals around,
the predator will be fed.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
If the predators
gets full, then you
can end up with something
that's like this.
And the way I think about this
is just in a group like this,
if 20 bears come in
and eat 20 of us,
then we hope that there
are 20 other people that
will get eaten first, so that
you know that the leftovers can
run off.
Right?
This is embodied in that joke
that people tell when they're
the two hikers in the woods, and
they see the mother bear that's
angry and one of the
hikers reaches down
and starts tying his shoelaces.
And the other thing the hiking
partner says why are you
tying your shoelaces?
You can't outrun a bear, right?
And the guys says,
well yeah I know that,
but I only have to outrun you.
That's predator satiation.
So if the predator
gets full, then you
can get something
that looks like this.
It's below some size,
below this n-min size,
they all get eaten by that bear.
And above it, the population
may be able to grow.
So this is a good
example of just
that it's an effective
form of cooperation.
Now can somebody explain--
Well, first of all,
does this lead to
a full bifurcation
if we add a death rate?
We're going to think about
this first seven seconds,
then we'll vote.
The question: if we add
a death rate to this,
does that lead to a fold
or saddle-node bifurcation?
I'm going to give you more
than seven seconds, because I
see a lot of brain activity.
Does this one lead to
a full bifurcation?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
The answer is, in
this case, yes.
So we'll say Allee effect is in
general the kind of thing that
leads to a full bifurcation.
In this case, it
definitely does.
So it's really very
important to be
able to take curves like
this, and figure out
what the bifurcation
diagram looks like.
And just remember that the
solid and dashed lines here
are very useful for
getting intuition
on what's going on, because
stable is telling us
that any perturbation away
from this point, it goes away.
So this is why we
draw arrows here.
Arrows come here.
So this is saying that starting
at 0, from a differential
equation standpoint
at least, you
can add a single individual
n, and that individual
will reproduce and gets to
whatever the effective carrying
capacity is at that delta.
So what we can do is we can
draw the same bifurcation
diagram here.
Where we look at the population
size as a function of delta.
And now it's actually somewhat
more interesting looking,
because in the absence
of this death rate,
we have it start at k.
So what's going to happen is
it's going to come like this.
And the reason we call
it a full bifurcation
is because these fixed points
fold over on themselves.
Now this is a bifurcation where
as a function is a control
parameter, it's not that
these fixed points exchange
stability, but rather that
the fixed points collide
and annihilate.
So in general, a bifurcation
is where something qualitative
happens to the fixed points.
In this case, the
number of fixed points
did not change as a function
of the control parameter.
Whereas in this
case, it does change.
But there are only certain
characteristic ways
in which these six points
are allowed to change.
So from this, we
can draw our arrows.
n equal to 0 is still a
stable point down here.
So we can draw.
This is where colored
chalk would be useful.
We can draw our arrows.
What do I do out here?
Now, the reason that we say
that this population experiences
a sudden transition,
or a tipping point,
is because you can imagine
that this death rate being
a slowly changing parameter.
So you could imagine
that it could
be a slow acidification
of the oceans,
or a slow increase in
the amount of fishing
that takes place here.
So then what can happen is that
the size of the population,
it's very healthy here.
It's pretty happy, happy.
Here it's maybe decreasing
some, but you might not
sound an alarm.
But what can happen is
that at some critical level
of environmental conditions,
some critical level of fishing,
for example, you can get
this catastrophic collapse
of the population.
Where over short periods of
time, it can suddenly collapse.
Indeed, this sort
of thing has been
observed in a number of
fisheries around the world.
So if you go to, for example,
the Monterey Bay Aquarium
in Monterey, California,
they have a very nice display
explaining how that space
ended up becoming and aquarium.
Because it used to
be a sardine fishery,
and was a very productive
fishery in the years leading up
to World War II.
But if you look at the
number of fish that
were caught as a function
of time, it goes up,
up, because there's
fishing more and more, then
all of the sudden, they
just presumably fish
too much and over a time
span of a few years,
the fishery collapsed,
and there were
just no more sardines to catch.
That whole street there
used to be canneries.
But then it all went
out of business.
And those buildings were
largely unused for many years.
But then eventually,
the aquarium
went and bought some of
them and refurbished them,
and now it's a
beautiful aquarium.
So I encourage you
to check it out.
But that being
said, the collapse
is probably still
bad, even though it
led to this nice
outcome eventually.
And what you can see is that not
only are these tipping points
or the sudden transitions
maybe undesirable in the case
of fishery, but it also would
be very difficult to reverse.
Because it's not that--
You couldn't imagined
that the bifurcation diagram
look rather different.
It could have looked like this.
What kind of
bifurcation is this?
So this is still
a transcritical.
It doesn't have to
be a line throughout,
because in principle there was
this unstable thing down here.
This is again, and, as a
function of some parameter,
we'll say delta.
And so you'd say, oh this is
a rather sudden transition.
In the sense that a
modest change in delta
will lead to a dramatic change
in the size of the population.
But there's something that's
very qualitatively different
about these situations.
Which is that, here you can
imagine that if you improve
the quality of the environment,
and then you reintroduce fish,
or maybe you don't even
have to introduce fish,
they can come from
a different area.
Then, just by improving the
quality of the environment,
you get recovery.
Whereas here, that's
very difficult to do,
because the system is
hysteretic, or has memory.
That means that
even if you improve
the quality of the
environment here,
it may be very difficult to get
back to your previous state.
People think that
they've seen this
in the context of
these transitions
in lake ecosystems, so-called
eutrophication transition,
where you get as
a result of maybe
runoff from agricultural uses.
You can get the sun
transitions of not
just a single population,
but of an entire ecosystem.
So the lake can
go from this thing
where it's nice and clear and
beautiful summer vacations
spot, to this really green
kind of algal take over.
And it can be very
difficult to get recovery.
There's was a question?
No?
And so the basic--
We'll say something
about the early
warning indicators.
Well maybe I'll say it now.
So based on the
review that you read,
there's this phenomenon
of critical slowing down
that tells us that
in principle, you
can anticipate the transitions
about to take place.
And the statement was that
the dominant eigenvalue
described in dynamics,
a system went
to 0 at one of these points.
Now, the systems they
were talking about
were presumably
systems like this.
This is a so-called zero
eigenvalue bifurcation,
were the eigenvalue goes to
0 at this point right here.
So here's a question for you.
Does the eigenvalue describe
the dynamics of a system
go to 0 at this point?
At transcritical.
In a transcritical bifurcation.
Do you understand the question?
I'll let you think
about it for 20 seconds,
because this is maybe
not totally obvious.
Do you need more time?
I'm wondering.
Maybe people are sufficiently
lost or confused.
They're not sure what--
Nod if you want more time.
OK.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
I'd say it's a kind
of a 50-50 thing.
So go ahead and
turn to you neighbor
and try to figure out, using
some combination of math
and graphical analysis,
whether the bifurcate--
Whether at this
transcritical bifurcation
the eigenvalue goes to 0.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
PROFESSOR: It sounds like
the discussion is maybe
gone to completion.
Let's go ahead and vote again.
The question is, does
the dominant eigenvalue
of this system go to
0 at this point here?
The trans critical bifurcation.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Alright.
It doesn't seem like it's
had much of an effect.
I see that one person has
been convinced of something.
I don't know if he's
actually convinced,
of if he was just
surrounded and bullied.
All right, so what are
some different ways
of thinking about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Well,
one of my neighbors
decided to actually
just lineralize
that equation at that point.
PROFESSOR: All right.
AUDIENCE: If you were
completely into you intuition,
this would be a way to check.
PROFESSOR: Right OK.
And now in general, in
life, I'm a big believer
when you're confronted
with some question,
you should first
think about it, what
you should guess based
on whatever intuition
might be available to you.
And then after you have made
a guess based on intuition,
then you go and you
do the calculation.
Which in this case,
linearizing around.
And where do linearize around?
Around the fixed point.
I would say that you
really want to linearize
maybe not around-- You get the
same answer if you lineralize
around 0, but you really want
to, I think conceptually,
you want to linearize around
this stable fixed point.
Right?
Because, in some ways, it's
the stable fixed point that
the system is sitting in, and
you want to know how is it that
you're-- How is it is you're
going to react when you get
perturbed away from
that fixed point?
And you do get the same answer.
The thing is that it's true
that the eigenvalue describing
the dynamics around this
unstable fixed point
also goes to zero.
But that's because, I think
the rules of mathematics
somehow say that the fixed
points are going to have
to do something similar.
So I think you do also
find the eigenvalue here
as it goes to 0,
but conceptually
that's not the eigenvalue
that you actually
want to know about.
Do you see why I'm saying that?
Again, the eigenvalue
here is going to 0.
We can try to explore
this a little bit,
but I just want to kind of
tie this together and say--
These local bifurcations
that you have maybe
heard about, which is that
this fold bifurcation,
the transcritical bifurcation,
and also the Hopf bifurcation.
So the Hopf is one
that looks where
you have a stable
fixed point that goes--
And in terms of
an unstable line,
you end up getting oscillations.
So that's where
you have something
that that's going to look like--
but now that I'm drawing this,
I'm a little bit--
Is there a difference
between a Hopf and a
pitchfork bifurcation?
AUDIENCE: It's whether you
have oscillations or not.
You can't really show that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So as drawn, it's
either or both, or?
AUDIENCE: It's both.
PROFESSOR: OK well.
I'll say that this thing also
the eigenvalue goes to 0 here.
Because I guess,
in this-- You don't
have to have
oscillations in order--
And it depends on the
higher dynamic systems.
But again, this is another
0 eigenvalue bifurcation.
And so the statement is
that in principle, you
can use this fact that
the eigenvalue goes to 0,
this thing called
critical slowing down,
to measure some changes in
the dynamics of the system
before, in this case,
you get collapse,
or before, in this case,
you get extinction.
The issue maybe is that
in this transition,
there really is
something big that
happened at the bifurcation.
So you really want to
have an early warning
signal because there's
a dramatic change,
and it may be
difficult to reverse.
Whereas here, the population
size is smoothly going to 0.
And once you get down to your
last two California condors,
you know that you're in trouble.
You don't need any sort
of fancy early warning
indicator based on fluctuations
or return time, and so forth.
Instead, just the
number is maybe
your best measure for the
health of the population.
So I think that yeah, maybe
I won't do the linearization,
but I encourage you to do it.
Because, that's what's
going to be relevant.
In particular, what
you want to know
is if there's some-- If you
linearize around there some,
just be clear, there's
some n equilibrium.
OK there's some equilibrium,
and then you want to ask,
well OK now you want to say
if your n is equal to some n
equilibrium, plus some epsilon.
Then, if you plug it
into the N dot function,
you should get an
equation that is
something where
this epsilon dot is
going to be equal to something.
What should it be equal to?
Something times epsilon.
And what something?
AUDIENCE: What we've
been calling lambda?
PROFESSOR: What we've
been calling labmda.
So this is saying that if
you go a little bit away
from the equilibrium,
so small epsilon here,
that epsilon-- The solution
to this is an exponential,
it's going to get
exponential decay,
assuming that lambda is what?
Negative.
And that's the
definition of-- is
When we say this is
a stable fixed point,
this is unstable, that's
equivalent to saying
that the lambda here is
negative and the lambda here
is positive.
AUDIENCE: That's a
very easy argument.
They exchange stability.
So you know that lambda
has to be completely 0.
PROFESSOR: Yes,
this is the point.
So we know that lambda here is
positive lambda-- I'm sorry,
lambda here is negative,
lambda here is positive.
These fixed points
at this point,
they're going to exchange
stability so that
means they had to be equal.
And where they exchange
is when it crosses.
So they both-- Well, I
guess independently this
went-- We should be
able to draw this,
although I'm a
little bit worried
that once I try
to draw something
I'm going to get confused.
But this is a useful exercise.
In particular, if we plot
as a function of delta.
So here, we have the lambdas,
and we have this delta.
and a delta equal to r
what's going to happen
is that we're going
to get the one
guy's going to go like this.
Something like that.
Given, that the fixed points
went from stable to unstable,
unstable to stable, so
they had to cross 0.
So if they both cross
0 at that point,
they're going to
be equal n zero.
You guys agree?
AUDIENCE: Do we know that the
eigenvalues are going to change
linearly with the death rate?
PROFESSOR: No.
So in general, they don't.
I'm trying to think if
close to the bifurcation,
whether I can say.
The mathematicians I'm
sure can say something.
I'm not going to.
AUDIENCE: Does this
also mean that whenever
we're on a steady state,
approaching bifurcation,
we'll always see the
critical slowing down?
If it's a stable fixed
point at a critical value.
PROFESSOR: I think that the
statement is that in principle,
critical slowing down occurs.
But that does not mean
that you'll necessarily
be able to see it.
Because it could be, there's
just too much noise, or this,
or that.
AUDIENCE: So something that
I was thinking about related
to that is-- So in this case,
it seems like everything
about the system, the
fluctuations, or anything,
should be getting very
small, as you approach that.
PROFESSOR: In principle,
the fluctuations
are supposed to grow.
Although this is assuming
that the strength of the noise
is constant.
And in this case, the
strength of the noise
may not be constant, because
if it's demographic noise,
and the size of your
population is going down.
This is actually
subtle then, I think.
And when we typically
talk about these dynamics,
we're assuming that there's
an added noise source that
is independent of the variable.
But if it's demographic
fluctuations
you're talking about,
that that won't be true.
I think that it's
also useful to draw,
to get some intuition
around this,
based on this idea of
an effective potential.
So these are
one-dimensional systems,
which means you can always write
down an effective potential.
And in this case, what it's
going to look like is--
This is some u effective as
a function of the population
size.
And up here, we have
some stable state here
that corresponds to something
that looks like this.
So it starts out maybe at k.
What happens is, as the
death rate increases,
this thing kind of turns-- Or,
maybe I didn't quite make it.
So what you see is
that as the death rate
here-- So, as we go down
the death rate is going up.
So that what happens is
the effective potential,
describing the dynamics of the
population near the equilibrium
is broadening out.
So you can think
about the dynamics
as being equivalent to
an overdamped particle
in effective potential.
So for example, for those of
you that have studied single
molecule biophysics
kinds of things,
this could be thought of as
a [? poly-centered ?] bead
that's trapped in
a the laser trap.
And as you turn down
the power of your laser,
then the spring constant
describing the dynamics
of that B in the trap, it
gets weaker and weaker.
So the potential
broadens, and that
means that for fixed injection
noise-- fixed temperature-- you
get these effects, where the
fluctuations will increase
in magnitude, and
you get an increase
in this autocorrelation time.
Because for example,
the bead in the trap,
the autocorrelation
time is indeed
just equal to the relaxation
time of the bead in the trap.
And the bifurcation
occurs right at this point
here, where you see that
this local potential is,
or the local minimum,
is disappearing.
That's when this stable
fixed point is gone.
And then you just
kind of fall off here.
And that's what leads
to this collapse, which
I have covered up.
That leads to the bifurcation.
And you should, for
example, be able to draw
an effective potential
here as well.
But I'll let you play with it.
But you can see the location
of this unstable fixed
point shifting as well.
I'm not sure how
good my drawing is.
Because in principal,
this unstable fixed point
should have to come together.
I'm not sure if that's
very clear in my drawing.
Just to summarize
this discussion,
I think there are
a few ways that you
can think of these early
warning indicators.
And there's a diagram
that I like to make,
that I think makes things
more clear, for me, at least.
Which is that if you
look at this population
as a function of time, it goes.
And if there's an environment
quality as a function of time.
If the environment
has a perturbation,
then the population will shrink,
and then you'll get recovery.
And this thing here tells you
about the time for recovery.
And this basic phenomenon
critical slowing down
tells you that as the
tipping point approaches,
as you approach the
bifurcation, that time
to recover from this
perturbation is going to grow.
Of course, the other
thing that you can say
is that even in the absence
of a defied perturbation, even
if the environment is
constant over time,
there could just a natural
noise in the system that
will fluctuate, just
like temperature,
for the bead in the trap.
And principle, then
you can measure
the size of the
fluctuations, the variance,
as well as the
autocorrelation time
tau, which is, for civil
systems, equal to t.
And this also grows as you
approach the bifurcation
AUDIENCE: Is it [? clear ?]
that-- Because the perturbation
[INAUDIBLE] that you're talking
about is I think n [INAUDIBLE]
perturbed n into
epsilon, and then it
relaxes the steady state.
Is it [INAUDIBLE] to
perturb the environment?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So that's a good question.
What I've been talking
about is a situation
where you really literally pull
it away, and then you let go.
And that's equivalent for
in the bead in the trap,
that you pull the bead
away, and then you let go,
and you watch it come back.
The situation in the
case of the environment
is that, if it's a kind of
a sudden shift-- It could
be anything, it could be a brief
change in-- Well it could just
be delta.
So it could be that over
some period of time,
the death rate increases,
or some period of time,
the growth rate decreases.
Or it could be that for--
The perturbations don't
have to be bad, they
can also be good,
and you actually get the same.
The principal for small
perturbations to go,
it's the same thing anyway.
So these are early
warning indicators
of an impending
transition that are
based on temporal indicators.
And one of the things that we've
been excited about in my group
is actually just trying
to measure these things
in a well controlled
laboratory population.
Since in our case,
we're using yeast
that are engaging in what you
might call a group hunting
behavior, where they secrete an
enzyme that breaks down sugar,
and that kind of leads to
this cooperative growth.
And at least in that case,
we can experimentally
measure an increase
in all of these things
as we approach this bifurcation.
The other thing you
might think about
is what happens for spatially
extended populations?
We'll talk more about spatial
populations on Thursday,
but just while we're here,
it's useful to think about it.
So instead of thinking about
just n as a function of time,
now you want to think about
density of population.
So one thing that
people talked about
is that-- Sorry, this is
not a function of time,
it's now a function
of position x.
Density is a
function of position.
Now, environment is a
If you have a uniform
environment over position
or space, then in
principle you can
look at density fluctuations.
And this is something that
people have talked about.
One of things that
we have argued
is that there should be a
spatial analog to this recovery
time.
So that corresponds
to a situation
where you have environment
as a function of position.
Like for example, we have
a sharp boundary, or just
a region of poor quality.
And in that case, you
can look at the density
as a function of position, and
you get some linked scale here.
So the statement here is
that, just because you're
in a region of high
quality doesn't
mean that you're at your
equilibrium density,
because if you're
close to a poor region,
so if you're close
to hunting grounds,
then you'll get local
depletion of the population.
You have to get some distance
away from a bad region
before you get your equilibrium.
That distance or
recovery length tells you
about the quality
of the environment.
And it's the quality of the
environment at this region,
the good region.
Where you are.
At least in the
laboratory, this is
something that's
actually much easier
to measure than other things.
Because, this is a
deterministic phenomenon.
You don't have to measure
fluctuations over time
with a high quality time series.
You don't have to wait for
a perturbation in time,
like a drought, and
look at recovery.
Instead, you just take
advantage of natural variations
in quality of the environment
over space, position, and then
you measure profiles.
We have a collaboration
with a professor
at the University of Pisa who
does field ecology experiments
with these algal mats on
intertidal communities,
on islands in the Mediterranean.
And we have a
[? pronates ?] that we
can measure this in those
island communities as well.
Are there any questions
about this stuff
before we switch gears?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In that example, is
it-- How much control can you
have over actually [? saying ?]
the quality to the environment?
PROFESSOR: So in that
manipulation, what they did was
they basically go in and
they-- So there these,
they're like miniature
forest somehow.
So they're little-- They have
alternative stable states.
What they actually do, they
go and they like chip away
at the rock to
remove the things.
And they do it over some range.
So they experimentally
basically make it a
challenging environment.
And apparently, they have
permission to do this.
So don't try that at
home without asking
the proper authorities.
Any other questions about this?
So I think that the nice
thing about studying
all these dynamics just
for a single population,
is that it really clarifies the
essential ingredients, in order
to get things like
sudden transitions.
Of course, in
natural populations,
we have many, many
species and tracking
in lots of complicated ways.
But we would like to
understand those things,
but I think since
it's so complicated,
you kind of like, oh
anything can happen,
and you get a little
bit discouraged
from thinking deeply about it.
Because, you just think it's
going to be too complicated
to try to understand.
I very much like the idea
of trying to really hone
your intuition on the simplest
possible situation like this,
and then bringing that intuition
to more complicated or complex
situations.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
partially [? adjust ?]
But what I want to ask
you is whether any of this
can be applied to human society?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
So whether this could be
applied to human society.
It's a good question.
People certainly try to.
I think you'll always have to
decide what we mean by apply.
I would say that this
basic idea that there
could be these
feedback loops that
can lead to sudden transitions
in complex systems.
I think this is a very robust
phenomenon, in the sense
that I think if you have
strong enough interactions,
then I think you kind
of expect it to be true.
Another question is whether you
could quantitatively predict
when that's going to happen.
There was a recent article
written in science or nature
about potential tipping
points in human society
on a global scale.
Things in terms of
productivity of crops.
And so they have a
question mark about,
they say 2050, question
mark, collapse maybe.
I say it's very important to be
thinking about these things in.
But the question is what to do,
whether given the uncertainties
and your knowledge of where
these tipping points might
occur, it's always hard to
know whether you could make
a strong argument saying, oh
we have to stop fishing here
because it's going to collapse.
There's always uncertainty
in your decision making.
But certainly in the context
of climate regime shifts,
people are worried
about these sorts
of feedback loops and the
North Atlantic Oscillation
and so forth.
And I'm not at all
an expert for that,
so I don't know whether
we should be worried.
But it's at least
good to remember
that systems can respond in
dramatic ways to small changes.
And then, you have to decide
what to do with that knowledge,
and I think that's more
of a judgement call.
AUDIENCE: In the time
example, you had death,
it was a death rate.
Is that in a [INAUDIBLE] space?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I want to be a little
bit maybe more clear.
The claim is that-- Like
the death, the delta there
that we're thinking
about, that didn't
have to be the perturbation.
It could be, but it
didn't have to be.
When we're plotting the
bifurcation diagram,
we're assuming implicitly
somehow that there's
a separation of time scales,
such that this delta might
be changing very slowly,
and then other things
are changing more rapidly.
So this bifurcation
diagram, it's
really that you're tracking it.
So in the context of this
n as a function of delta,
this thing goes like this.
And the idea is that
oh, slowly you're
getting more and more
agricultural runoff,
or the temperature
is increasing.
Doesn't have to be human
induced, by the way,
it could be something else.
So the idea is that the
population is slowly
changing like this.
And then eventually maybe
you get this collapse.
Now, a perturbation could
be something that could just
be a drought, or something that
is independent of this delta.
But the statement is
that, over here-- Now I'm
going to be mixing things.
At low delta, the claim is that
you should get a dip and then
rapid recovery.
As the delta gets bigger,
you get maybe even
a larger-- The same perturbation
could [? principally ?] do
a larger dip, and it takes
longer to get recovery.
This actually brings
up another point,
which is that these could all
be the same perturbations.
So this is a case where delta
is increasing as we go down.
So they could be the
same perturbation here.
Here you survive,
here you survive.
But then that same perturbation
that was survived here
could be the same
magnitude drought, just as
delta increases
you expect this--
This may be able
to push the system
past the unstable
fixed point, because
of a loss of resilience.
This is something
that we've seen
in a variety of
different contexts.
I think it's a very
general phenomenon.
Just because the
separation here is
some measure of the
resilience of the population,
or the ability of the population
to withstand perturbations.
We can see that the
resilience shrinks as we
get close to this bifurcation.
Did that answer your question?
Sort of?
Not really.
AUDIENCE: No, but it
answered another question.
PROFESSOR: It answered
another question?
Oh good.
I'm glad that I
answered something.
But what was your--
Because you were saying
is it the death rate that is
causing this perturbation?
AUDIENCE: Well, no.
I was wondering for
[? per ?] space.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Oh yes, I forgot.
Yes, I do remember
that you did ask that.
So the idea here is that this
could be a region that we fish,
and this could be region that
we don't fish, for example.
Or it could be
that, here there's
just not as much food for the
organism as there are here.
So just the idea
is that you would
need kind of a sudden sharp
boundary between regions
of different quality.
And that's kind of
the situation where
you would be able to measure
this recovery length.
And the basic
reason for that, is
that if the environmental
quality is something
that changes very slowly,
then the population density
will just track that.
So then you can't use that to
measure this recovery length.
Of course, the same
statement is true here.
That if you have environmental
perturbations that
are changing slowly
over time, then
that also can
complicate this picture.
Any other questions
about that before we
move towards
multispecies ecosystems?
We're going to start
with two species.
So what I'm going
to do is I want
to spend the rest
of the class talking
about Lotka-Volterra
populations.
And we're going to
move the rock, paper,
scissors discussion to
Thursday, because it's
a nice spatial example anyways.
So let's think about
Lotka-Volterra.
Now, there's a lot.
Lotka-Volterra
competition model.
So the assumption
is that we're going
to make here is that we
have these two species that
going to be
interacting, but they're
going to interact in
kind of the simplest way
that you might imagine.
Which is that, if we plot the
derivative of population size
n1 as a function of time, we get
something that looks like this.
Now the first
thing that you want
to do when you see something
like this is just to make
sense the basic equation.
In particular, in the
absence of the other species,
what happens to
these populations?
We're going to assume here maybe
first is that r1 and r2 are
both greater than 0.
It's in the absence
of the other species.
Do these populations
survive or not?
Ready?
Three, we're going do it
A, yes, B, no, our typical.
All right, absence of a species.
ready?
Three, two, one, survival?
Yeah, they survive.
For sure, because I told
you that these guys are
greater than 0, that means--
We can think about n1.
In the absence n2,
what is this equation?
Logistic.
Now, if we wanted to think
about these as describing
competitive interactions,
what does that tell us
about the sign of the betas?
Are the betas greater than
0, or are they less than 0?
I'll think about
it for 10 seconds.
All right.
Do you need more time?
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Competitive means that the
betas are greater than 0.
And what is the assumption
somehow that's going into this?
And we should remember that this
is a minus everything up here.
AUDIENCE: I guess that
somehow these two things
are-- there's a fixed
amount of some resource,
that both of these things need.
PROFESSOR: OK, so there
could be some fixed resource.
AUDIENCE: It's basically like
an effective carrying capacity.
PROFESSOR: That's
right, so somehow it's
modulating the effect
of carrying capacity.
And how is it that you
would describe these betas?
AUDIENCE: Sort of seems like
you expect that the beta should
be probably less than one.
[INAUDIBLE] I guess it doesn't
have to be less than one.
Compared to how well
n1-- and individual of n1
takes up some of this.
This is how much [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: That's right.
I think that's right.
Now I think we--
There's a question
about how explicitly to be
thinking about these resources.
Because it could be, it doesn't
have to be one resource.
And this is of course, a
very phenomenological model.
It's lumping all the
interact-- All of the ways
in which a species interacts in
just a single parameter beta.
But it's somehow, the betas
are telling us something
about how much does a
member of the other species
inhibit my growth, as compared
to a member of my own species?
Because we have this n1 here,
and just this species one
will naturally lead to
a carrying capacity k1,
you only have species one.
Now, the betas are telling
you something about
how much overlap they
have in terms of maybe
[? niche ?] or so.
Now, if the betas
are small, it means
that they're not competing
with each other very much.
The betas could be larger than
one, and what that's saying
is that a member of
this other species
is inhibiting my growth
more than a member
of my own species.
So the standard way to
analyze these equations
is to look at these isoclines.
So basically, if you say, OK
well n1 dot is equal to zero,
what does that mean?
Well, we can just see that
that's equivalent to saying
that it's n1 plus beta1,2
n2 is equal to k1.
So this is giving us a
relationship between n1 and n2.
What do these look like on a
plane, n1 versus n2 drawings?
So the parabola, it's a line.
And indeed, we can think about
what happens when each of these
is equal to one
thing or another.
So if n1-- If n2 is
equal to 0, this thing
is going across at k1.
And that makes sense,
because we already
decided that in
the absence of n2,
this thing is just
following logistic growth,
where the species one
will grow and go to k1.
And that's a stable
fixed point that n1 dot
has to be equal to zero.
It's a fixed point, so n1
dot has to be equal to 0.
And it's going to cross
at this other point
here where n2 is going to
be some k1 over beta 1, 2.
And then we end up with a line.
Now if we go, and we ask
what n2 dot is equal to,
and this is equal
to 0, we're going
to end up with something
that looks very similar.
But now it's going to be n2 plus
beta 2, 1, n1 is equal to k2.
This is also going to be a line.
Given what I have said, how many
different qualitative outcomes
can you get in this model?
Where we just assume--
Where we have beta-- Overall
I think we're thinking about
competitive interactions.
How many cases do
we need to consider?
Alright, it's going to be a, 0.
Do you guys understand
what I mean by cases?
No?
I mean, how many different
kind of qualitative outcomes
can there be in terms of species
one or species two winning,
or can you get coexistence?
Or how many different kind
of qualitative outcomes
can there be?
And if you're confused, you
can not vote, or give me
an unhappy face.
OK, ready?
Three, two, one.
So
We have many Es.
And can somebody
explain why it that this
is the case, without invoking
that you've already studied
this and you know the answer?
AUDIENCE: If you add another
line, completely on top,
or under, or it can cross too.
PROFESSOR: That's
right, that's right.
So the next thing I was about
to do is draw another line.
And the reason I stopped is
because there are actually
four different ways in which
this other line can be drawn.
And basically, you can have
another line that does one.
You can have two.
You can have three.
And you can have four.
OK?
These two cases-- So
this is we'll say one.
I don't know what
order i did it.
Two, three, and four.
Two and three, in both cases we
have the crossing of the lines.
So maybe does that mean
they're the same outcome,
the same qualitative outcome?
No.
And what will end up
happening here is that we're
going to get cases of--
So you basically
can get that species
one dominates independent
of starting condition,
assuming that both are
present at the beginning.
Species two could dominate.
They could coexist, or
you get bistability.
History dependent,
mutual exclusion.
I just want to draw.
So this one here was the-- We
had a dashed line for n1 dot
and we had the
solid line for this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Where is
[? the breaking ?] [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So I guess
if you swap the labels,
or so, you're saying?
I guess in the case
that if one of them
is just above the other one,
then you can distinguish them.
So if you have a
dashed line here,
you have a solid line here,
that means that they--
AUDIENCE: How do I
distinguish case 2 and case 3?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Maybe we
should try to figure out
which one's which, and then we
can figure it out from there.
Can somebody remind us,
what are these lines again?
Why are we drawing them,
or what do they mean?
So they're not actually
quite a fixed point.
It's a no incline.
What's the difference
between these things?
If we have a fixed point
here, what we're saying
is that both n1 dot and
n2 dot are equal to 0.
Fixed point means that
if you start right there,
you'll stay right there.
We're not yet say
anything about stability.
And this is going to be very
relevant for Sam's question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The axes
are definitely labeled.
I think I may agree, but I'm
a little worried that I'm-- If
you're happy I'm happy.
OK let's-- A fixed point of this
pair of equations will be when
both of the derivatives
are equal 0.
And that's not the
line that we've drawn.
The lines that we've drawn are
just when one or the other one
is equal to 0.
So what does that mean
about in case four,
is it possible well
to have coexistence?
No.
Because there's no
fixed one in the middle.
The only case it's
possible to get coexistence
is either line
two or line three.
But that tells us
there's a fixed point,
it doesn't tell us about the
stability of the fixed point,
though.
What we'll find is
that in one case,
it's a stable fixed point,
you get coexistence.
In the other case, it's
an unstable fixed point,
and you get bistability.
What we're going
to do now is we're
going to ask and try to
figure out in which case,
how do we label these things?
So what we'll do is ask,
first of all in line one,
we want to figure out,
is that a situation
where we know it's
not going to be
coexistence are bistability,
but is it going to a situation
where a species one wins,
or when species two wins?
But, if you want, you can
vote for one of the others.
I don't want to
constrain your choices.
So it's going to be a is one
wins, B, two wins, not three
wins.
This is something else.
I'm going to give you a
minute to think about what
might be going on here.
So the question is
put in situation one.
Oh no, I did that wrong.
In this.
For the solid line,
this is what we're
asking for n1 is equal to 0.
This is just equal to k2.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: There's
other [? null ?] lines.
PROFESSOR: You want
more [? null lines? ?]
I feel like there are lots
of lines up there already.
AUDIENCE: Where n equals
0 [? null ?] lines.
The axes are actual
[? null ?] lines.
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
Yeah, that's true.
AUDIENCE: That helps-- I'm
confused between labels.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I see.
OK I'm hesitant to draw
anything more up on the board.
But it is true that the axes
are also [? null ?] lines.
Because we have n's up there.
I'll give you another
20 seconds to try
to figure out this case one.
Which of the species
is going to win?
And let's go ahead and
vote, and see where we are.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
So there's a slight
majority that
are agreeing that in
this case, it's going
to be that one is going to win.
And I think that it's a little
bit hard to figure it out
completely, but what I will say
is that in the case where we're
down here, what this means is
that k1 divided nu beta 1,2
is larger than k2.
Now the question
says, what happens
in the limit of-- If species
two does not hurt species one?
Well that's when
beta 1,2 goes to 0.
And that's the situation
where this goes up.
So this is saying
that if the beta 1,2--
And then we can figure
out where this line is
as well, because this thing
is K2 divided by beta 2,1.
So if species to
doesn't hurt to see one,
but species one really
hurts species two,
that's going to be the
limit where species one
is going to win.
We are out of time.
Maybe what we'll do is
start class on Thursday
by-- I'll start with
this on the board,
and then we'll complete
these four possibilities,
to try to get some
intuition about it.
And also draw these options.